So, what happens to the neurotransmitters once they're released from the
synaptic vesicles? A variety of things can happen. One, those neurotransmitters
can be taken back up by that neuron. This process is called reuptake. However,
there are some groups that prevent reuptake. For example, maybe you have heard
of Selective Serotonin Reuptake Inhibitors. If someone were to take an SSRI, it
means that once those neurotransmitters are released Into the synaptic cleft.
The drug prevents those neurotransmitters from being taken back up by that same
neuron. That allows for more serotonin in the synaptic cleft and eventually
those serotonin neurotransmitters can attach to the receptor sites. Another
mechanism is enzymes will actually break down those neurotransmitters. In doing
so, they will not be able to attach to receptor sites. Once the
neurotransmitter attaches to the receptor, it can have 1 or 2 effects.
Neurotransmitters can have an inhibitory effect or, an excitatory effect.
Inhibitory effect is going to decrease the likelihood of the next neuron
firing. Whereas an excitatory effect is going to increase the likelihood of the
next neuron firing.